let F be the function given by f of X is
equal to the square root of x plus 4
minus 3 over X minus 5 if F if X does
not equal 5 and it's equal to C if x
equals 5 and say if F is continuous at x
equals 5 what is the value of C so if we
know that F is continuous at x equals 5
that means that the limit the limit as X
approaches 5 of f of X is equal to f of
5 this is the definition of continuity
and they tell us that f of 5 when x
equals 5 the value of the function is
equal to C so this must be equal to C so
what we really need to do is figure out
what the limit of f of X as X approaches
5 actually is now if we just try to
substitute 5 into the expression right
up here in the numerator you have 5 plus
4 is 9 the square root of that is
positive 3 the principal root is
positive 3 3 minus 3 is 0 so you get a 0
in the numerator and then you get 5
minus 5 in the denominator so you get 0
in the denominator so you get this
indeterminate form of 0 over 0 and in
the future we will see that we do have a
tool that allows us or gives us an
option to attempt to find limits when we
get this indeterminate form it's called
a la Patel's rule but we can actually
tackle this with a little bit of fancy
algebra and to do that I'm going to try
to get this radical out of the numerator
so let's rewrite it so we have the
square root of x plus 4 minus 3 over X
minus 5 and anytime you see a radical
plus or minus something else to get rid
of the radical what you can do is
multiply by the radical doing the or if
you have a radical minus 3 you multiply
by the radical plus 3 so in this
situation you just multiply the
numerator by square root of x plus 4
plus 3 over the square root of x plus 4
plus 3 we obviously have to multiply the
numerator and the denominator by the
same thing so that we actually don't
change the value of the expression if
this right over here had a plus 3 then
we would do a minus 3 here and this is a
technique that we learn in algebra or
sometimes in precalculus class to
rationalize usually denominators but to
rationalize numerators or denominators
it's also a very similar technique that
we use often times to get rid of complex
numbers usually usually in denominators
but if you multiply this out and I
encourage you to do it you notice this
has the pattern that you learned in
algebra class is the difference of
squares something minus something times
something plus something so the first
term is going to be the first two
something squared so square root of x
plus four squared is X plus four and the
second term is going to be the second
something or you're going to subtract
the second something squared so you're
going to have minus three squared so
minus nine and then in the denominator
you're of course going to have X minus
five X minus five times the square root
of x plus four plus three and so this
has I guess you could say simplified to
although it's not arguably any simpler
but at least we've gotten our radical
we're early just playing around with it
algebraically to see if we can then
substitute x equals five or if we can
somehow simplify it to figure out what
the limit is and when you simplify the
numerator up here you get X plus four
minus nine well that's X minus 5 over X
minus five times the square root of x
plus four plus three and now it pops out
at you both the numerator and the
denominator are now divisible by X minus
five so you can have a completely
identical expression if you say that
this is the same thing you can divide
the numerator and the denominator by X
minus five if you assume X does not
equal 5 so this is going to be the same
thing as 1 over square root of x plus 4
plus 3 for X does not for X does not
equal 5 which is fine because in this
first the first part of this function
definition this is for the case where X
does not equal 5 so we could actually
replace this and this is this is a
simpler expression with 1 over square
root of x plus 4 plus 3
and so now when we take the limit as X
approaches 5 we're going to get closer
and closer to 5 where you get X values
closer and closer to 5 but not quite at
5 we can use this expression right over
here so the limit of f of X as X
approaches 5 is going to be the same
thing as the limit of 1 over the square
root of x plus 4 plus 3 as X approaches
5 and now we can substitute a 5 in here
it's going to be 1 over 5 plus 4 is 9
principal root of that is 3 3 plus 3 is
6
so if C is equal to 1/6 so if C is equal
to 1/6 then the limit of our function as
X approaches 5 is going to be equal to f
of 5 and we are continuous at x equals 5
so it's 1/6